personal do so I think that a hundred
years ago or so you know science was the
domain of you know the hair professor
the sort of white male old man that had
all this prestige show because he
understood this thing that that regular
people couldn't understand you know
science right and so there was this it
wasn't systematic you know this sort of
feedback loop that made that that was
purposely started here that I am doing
this rarefied thing right that you the
normal person can't get you know you
have to be Albert Einstein you have to
be you know whoever right and that mere
mortals can't cope in this world and
that has become made it so that people
are afraid of science they think science
they think it's too hard and then they
also have this stereotype of this old
guy like you know why would I want to be
like that these guys were never athletes
right and so I think that there's that
this the stereotype of these boring a
social you know drones that's who
becomes a scientist I can't tell you how
many times you know I've gone to a
dinner party and I mean and these are
learning people or anyone where they say
what do you do and I say oh I'm a
geneticist and the hand comes up and
they say oh in fourth grade you know my
teacher and I couldn't learn site you
know blah blah blah and I couldn't learn
science from then on if I were to say oh
the Renaissance I never got the
Renaissance ER Oh French literature oh
no oh business business man oh you know
like I would be considered a moron I
mean like why is it okay for more for
our country or anyone to say I can't do
science I mean science is what gives us
the life we have right now you know
whether and it does have to be biology
just think about computer science I mean
you know those people are certainly text
messaging so they can do science right
and so it's so and I have to say this is
not um
particular to me this is every
scientists nightmare dinner party and we
got a lot of these right and it's so odd
because it would be unthinkable for me
to say I just didn't want to learn to
read right come on how many heroes do
you know in science right you know like
I mean if an athlete were to walk down
the street you would instantly recognize
him my colleague Eric wheesh house has a
Nobel Prize and people in Princeton
don't even know who he is right and so I
think that we don't have heroes right
and that is new because in the 50s you
know and earlier you know Einstein was a
hero sock was a hero you know Fleming
those were heroes and somehow culture
has changed that it's not cool and
heroic to do science and I think that's
kind of a pity right and and and I don't
think it's just movies I think it's a
much bigger thing it's what we've been
talking about that it's that our entire
country is turned off from science at a
really early age for both religious and
political and educational reasons right
and then there's no way to grapple with
that in popular you know no you know the
people are going to watch this show are
already self-selected your show to be
able to say maybe I could learn
something about science right in
otherwise they're not going to watch
this